hey guys I'm Eric Voss and yes I'm in a
new studio it's a whole work in progress
but I don't have time to talk about that
because Westworld just finished its
first season on HBO and like many of you
I'm sure I was totally blown away by the
show obviously this was way more than
just another HBO show with
self-indulgent violence and
sneaky-sneaky nudity oh right I should
not be watching this in public sorry kid
oh crap does this mean I have to go to
jail now I think it does okay I
shouldn't say anything more without a
quick spoiler warning trust me Theory
videos are just not as interesting
without watching the source material
first so go watch the show and then come
back here okay the season finale
confirmed one of the big theories of
Westworld fans have speculated about
online that William is a younger version
of the man in black and therefore their
two narratives are taking place in two
totally different time periods and
actually it's not just these two
storylines that are presented out of
chronological order the whole season is
ordered in a way to structure the
various reveals so that they'd have the
biggest impact so in this video I'm
gonna help you better understand
everything by reordering the story of
Westworld season 1 in chronological
order also I made another video that
specifically explains everything about
the endings so if you have any questions
or lingering confusion go check out that
video okay let's get started
West world's various storylines take
place across three major time periods
the first period is before the park
officially opens the second occurs a few
years later as the park was growing as a
tourist attraction and the third the
main time period the modern present time
occurs thirty years after that and
actually we now know what year the
present day time period takes place in
so the promotional site for the delos
corporation released a video on the
night of the premiere showing security
footage and the date on that footage is
June 15 20 50 now I should say that on
this website they have since removed
this video and replaced it with this
taking off the date so while they may
end up changing the year further down
the road like in season 2 the timeline
still holds up that means we can use
that date as an anchor and work our way
back to the beginning and since we know
that Arnold died 34 years before that
date that sets his death as April or May
2018 and the chronologically earliest
scenes are set in 2015 to 2018 in
forwards flashback in episode 3 as he
explained the parks early days to
Bernard
for three years we lived here in the
park refining the host before a single
guest set foot inside this is also
around the time when Arnold first
creates Dolores which we see at the
beginning of episode 10 then throughout
the season there are various scenes
where we see Bernard who we later
realizes actually Arnold in a flashback
having secret sessions with Dolores
encouraging her to continue to question
her reality and seek the maize and by
the way if you have any questions about
that maize check out my other video so
these all happen between 2015 and 2018
before the park officially opens when
Arnold was still feeling the grief of
losing his son and he became obsessed
with the idea that the hosts should
reach consciousness then in 2018 Arnold
reaches a breakthrough with Dolores
starting with this session that we see
in episode 4 you think the query will
make you smaller and sad I feel space is
opening up inside of me so Dolores is
creativity and how she expresses her
grief surprises Arnold and it convinces
him that hosts are capable of achieving
human consciousness and therefore the
park must be shut down this leads to a
disagreement between Arnold and Ford
resulting in Arnold ordering Dolores
merged with the murderous Wyatt
characters behavior to join Teddy and
massacring all the hosts along with
Arnold himself
we actually saw flashes of this Massacre
throughout the season but the whole
thing goes down officially in episode 10
so this scandal almost destroyed the
park but Ford managed to save it
suggesting that Arnold's death was a
suicide because he was working through
Dolores and Ford is able to cover up the
hosts gaining consciousness to keep the
park open
okay so West world opened officially a
little later in 2019 or 2020 and around
2022 starts the second major time period
of the show with young William and Logan
joining the story so at this point
Escalante has been buried in sand and
Dolores and Teddy had been reset on new
loops with Dolores as a farm girl who
dreams of escape and Teddy as her doomed
lover who keeps her home and in with her
parents and Teddy being killed by
outlaws so William as a young man and a
rep salute taking Dolores along with
them on his journey and everything we
see in this storyline the search for
slim the trip to pariah and meeting
Lawrence as Alonso the Train the chase
from the ghost nation and the arrival at
the former location of Escalante and
running to Logan in the Confederate owes
and Williams transition into a dark
violent killer with the black hat this
all takes place in
this second time period we also see the
photo of Williams Beyonce in future
white Juliet in Times Square which her
brother Logan carried around for some
reason fall from Williams bang of course
this would be discovered by Abernathy
thirty years later in the present so
from there Williams story is a little
less clear he implies to Dolores in
episode 10 that he had come back to the
park and went on the same journey with
her over and over and many of their
scenes from there out the season like
waking up in episode four or being on
the train in episode seven or refined in
the town in Episode eight episode ten
suggests that these all could be from
subsequent times with Dolores over the
years I know my mind is kind of breaking
as well but let's move on so in episode
8 the man in black William told Teddy
his backstory which fills in the gap of
the second time period he replaced Logan
in the delos corporation became a
primary funder for the park basically
keeping it afloat then he took over as a
Titan of industry and took over as a
majority shareholder of Westworld
meanwhile Arnold's scandal is suicide
was erased from history
Ford was credited as the sole Krait of
the park and after Arnold was long
forgotten about Ford constructed his
host Bernard and Arnold's image and the
two of them together wiped the memory of
every host who showed signs of
consciousness and gradually worked
together on Ford's master plan which I
get to in the other video and that
brings us to our final time period the
present-day around twenty fifty to
William now an older man returns to West
world after his wife's tragic suicide
seeking meaning he kills made the
homesteaders daughter and shocked by her
very human emotional response when she
attacks him he realizes that hosts may
be on their way to gaining consciousness
and actually hurting humans and he hopes
that this darker more dangerous side of
West world is what lies in Arnold's maze
that he's heard so much about and now he
intends to find it so everything that we
see with the man in black version of
William attacking Dolores scalp and
kissy using Lawrence and Teddy to find
Wyatt and Escalante and reuniting with
Dolores in hopes of learning the truth
about the maze this all takes place in
the present timeline meanwhile around
the same time Dolores is retracing her
footsteps alone on the journey she made
with William in those earlier years
that's why she experienced these visions
throughout the season in her past
storyline showing her the image of the
maze while everyone else around her
disappears
also at some point during the solo
wanderings Dolores got pulled in for
examination by Ford that was in episode
5 then when Dolores arrives in Escalante
in episode 9 with Logan stab wound from
the past timeline suddenly gone and she
went down under the church to remember
killing Arnold and fought and got
stabbed by the older version of William
that was all in the present in 2052 and
of course everything involving Ford's
new narrative and Bernard and LC
learning the truth about the park and
then Bernard maybe killing Elsie and
Teresa and Charlotte Pilate announced
Ford and then Bernard definitely killing
Teresa and Maeve achieving consciousness
and trying to escape the park with Felix
Hector and armistice this is all
obviously in the present as well so the
final images we see chronologically are
of Dolores and the other hosts beginning
forwards new narrative massacring board
and the west-world Board of Directors
while William happily realizes that the
horse serve actually dangerous now and
this could be fun and the rest of the
west-world employees are left scrambling
inside the park as Maeve Hector and
Armistice still run amok now part of
what made Westworld season once so
brilliant is that it foreshadowed the
reveal of this nonlinear chronology with
little clues while doing just enough to
throw off the scent so the two biggest
mr. X were in episode 3 & 4 so we see
Dolores and her present 20:52 time
period shooting rebus in the barn after
remembering the older William and then
escaping and shortly afterward finding
younger William joining him on their
storyline in the past so the show puts
these two scenes one after the other to
trick us into thinking that they're part
of the same storyline when really
they're just different scenes from two
parallel journeys thirty years apart the
other misdirect comes in the next
episode when Stubbs obviously in the
present timeline sends a host to escort
Dolores back into her loop we've got a
host making a pretty big deviation from
her lube which one the ranches daughter
from Sweetwater
Dolores is she accompanying a guest
unclear now the text says it's unclear
and that's just vague enough so that
when we see this random host show up to
take Dolores away from William in the
next scene 30 years earlier we can
assume that these storylines are
actually just separate events so
Westworld presented these scenes in this
order to trick us into assuming this
story was being told linearly so that as
all the little inconsistencies and
connections begin to pop up there at the
season it created the slow realization
that something deeper was going on and
all these clues were a lot more subtle
than Lawrence somehow in and up into
different storylines so let's look at
some of them first as William arrives in
Westeros episode 2 notice how the park
logo is different than the one we see in
all the other storylines in fact it's
the same retro logo that shows up on the
old computer that Bernard digs up in
episode 6 also the madam of the mariposa
brothel that greets them isn't made it's
this other host because maid have been
back in her previous loop as the
homesteader mother we also see that same
former Madam's show up in a West world
highlight reel that confuses Maeve back
in a lab then of course the Sweetwater
recruiter in the past storyline is a
Union soldier as opposed to the sheriff
in the present storyline and then of
course there were just like a ton of
parallel lines of dialogue echoed
between young William and older William
used to think this place was all about
pandering to your baser instincts it
doesn't cater to your lowest self it
reveals your deepest self because that's
what this place does right reveals your
true self you said this place was a game
last night I finally understood how to
play it
you know about games I don't play on the
deal who said anything about you playing
I play I used to believe there was a
path for everyone there's another old
friend of mine likes to say there's a
path for everyone so those are just some
of the clues that I found interesting
but I'm sure there are even more when
we'll go back and re-watch this season I
know I will be because we have plenty of
time before Westworld season 2 comes out
and again make sure to check out the
other video I made breaking down
everything that happened in the ending
of Westworld season 1 there's a lot of
interesting stuff in that video
definitely worth the watch ok thanks for
watching this video and let me know what
you think in the comments and then
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars and share this video with your
friends you can also contribute to us on
patreon so thanks so much to all of our
current donors and if you are currently
a patron we'd love your support ok you
can follow me on twitter at EI vos or
new rock stars on twitter at new rock
stars alright thanks for watching bye
[Music]